il ya beaucoup de scènes très très drôle
ou qu'on va jouer à qui comme dans le
film alors qui comme dans le film a déjà
été accusée à tort de tromperie josiane
est ce que c'était déjà arrivé à tort
arriver non mais attends non moi pas tu
auras raison mais en fait tout le monde
est hyper difficile trop charlie
attendant jamais la tornade jimena a
raison tout aussi donc gynéco bonsoir
avant oui plus maintenant maintenant
télécom refusé à tort tromper bonsoir ça
fait plus avant je faisais 20 ans
est ce que tu as avant je faisais
maintenant j'arrête et trompe damien
iehl amiens patron non non et non je
peux écouter ça il a mis un truc ni
ayant baissé a atteint bien d'accord
communiqué alors comme d'habitude c'est
comme ça je pense à noël nous parle on
dirait qu'on est dans les mots 2007 à
tournoi oui tu nous appelles tout moi
c'était à tort parce que j'étais dans
une école de maquillage et l'après midi
on s'est entraîné à acer du latex sur le
visage pour faire les les cicatrices et
c est mon ex était venu me chercher en
voiture à la sortie de l'école ouais et
il m'a embrassée et il a senti l'odeur
du latex 100 et crois que c'est une
capote
non et je me sens vraiment
[Rires]
mais cap était à 200 kilos elle camille
shalima centre d'où sa gratuité mais j'
aurais pu faire ça s'appelle rondes dans
la mode du rct séparément suspicieux
voilà il avait une feutrine accuse m
non mais vous non 86 fidèle des fidèles
à qui avoue des nouvelles voitures de
leurs grandes douches d'accord lui c'est
le seul moi j'ai une période malheureuse
pendant deux ans il ya quelques années
j'étais déjà tous en poste où j'ai été
accusé de plein de d'erreur enfin de
dérapages alors qu'il n'y a pas une qui
était vrai et en revanche quand je
trempe il était jamais piqué et voir où
gbagbo n'ont donc jamais qu'à cause de
vous lorsque vous jean laryngite d'une
laryngite
ça fait ça baisse ça fait dix ans passés
à kelly d'accord c'est du coup comme
dans les mosquées poussent alors si son
mec était passé par là l'abus
jean-michel merde tu n'arriveras
l'émission vous avez souvent voulu me
caser avec des agents à droite et à
gauche et moi je le faisais comme ça
pour rigoler mais je ne pensais pas
vraiment parfois j'avais une copine à ce
moment là et elle du coup elle prenait
soin premier degré quand je rentrais je
me faisait mal et challans ou dit sur
twitter qui a décroché le droit je suis
parti à 19h50
c'est un cast alliés toi alors moi ce
qui m'est arrivé très souvent c'est ce
qu'elle m'avait accusé à tort d'avoir de
l'avoir trompé qu'une personne est en
fait ça m'a donné l'idée de la tromper
avec la personne même marc énormément
puisque chez l'accusée atteinte au pire
vous c'est dégueulasse quoi c'est vrai
j'ai visionné toi mais c'est ça ton
prennent des crédits sur toi tu dis t'as
pas fini de te marier qui comme dans le
film a une super relation avec ses beaux
parents ou charlie est ce que tu as du
bowie moi j'ai une bonne relation ça va
trop bien et josiane en gros ils sont
morts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
passé présent futur très bon we know il
est obligé
moi je pressens rigoler ma chute mais je
ramène bruno à la maison elle est bien
sûr et frère ma mère elle même le
travail de bruno mois la maison mais
même là maintenant sur ma vie elle est
comme une folle mois à venir je ramène
gruel a annoncé bien il est propre
moi tu vécu mamelles à la maison bichot
lugar il est bon ici les bras mais les
riches mais les riches qui avoue mais le
gars arrêtez avec ça c'est des idées
reçues